- I wanna know 'cause you've been on SNL,
I wanna know, what are
your favorite characters
that you've ever gotten to play?
- Wow!
I mean, any time I was on camera at SNL,
15-year-old me was
extremely excited about it
but I mean, gosh, they all change.
- It is a certain energy
when you're there.
I've been there just performing and stuff.
- You've hosted.
- No, I didn't... no.
- You have to,
you would be a perfect host.
- It's such a commitment.
(Kelly chuckles)
(audience cheers)
I was actually in New York
when Blake Shelton hosted
'cause my ex manager--
- Oh, I was there for that.
He was great.
- I know.
But it's a commitment.
Y'all work all week.
People don't get it.
It's not, just Saturday night.
It's like all week long.
- No, it's a lotta work.
- Yeah.
I feel like you are someone
that would excel at it, though,
'cause you're hilarious
- Oh, really?
and you don't,
I feel like you would let them have fun
and have a good time.
- Oh, I would definitely
lean in and have a good time.
- Yeah. I feel like you
would be a great host.
I wanna see it.
- Okay. Okay.
Okay (laughs) (claps).
(audience cheers)
(Bobby laughs)
I love that.
Thank you. Thank you
- Blake was great.
Blake was fantastic.
- Do you remember
your very first time that you were on SNL?
'Cause you said your 15-year-old
self was freaking out.
So what was your first, do you remember?
- Yeah, I totally remember.
It was like space camp.
- [Kelly] Ah.
It was nuts.
The first episode was
the only one I enjoyed,
because I was like,
(Kelly laughs)
"I'm here I can't believe it!"
And then it was a job after that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, no, I definitely
in between two scenes
in my first episode,
ran full speed across the studio
and changed really fast
'cause we're on live TV
and then I had like a minute and a half--
- Yeah. But you think
it's quick change, yeah.
- And I was just standing
there going like (lips trill),
(Kelly laughs)
"I guess I'm very excited
to be here." (chuckles)
- (laughs) Yeah. Oh my God.
You got your pocket
protector on, you're like,
"Really..." (laughs).
- Yeah, I was very...
my old SNL book (laughs).
- (laughs) Love it.